I know you've all been holding back your
opinions of doom while you wait for
cliff bleszinski xinput but good news
you don't have to wait anymore because
the gears of war designer has finally
weighed in on the gorgeously gory game
I'm Kate and this is your chainsaw
execution news update writing on Twitter
Bleszinski said he's enjoying the game a
lot but had one minor piece of criticism
and it's the same one he has four gears
of war okay some rapid-fire doom
thoughts weapons feel good so far good
to see some satanic stuff in there
awesome to be on the Martian surface
love the mystery of who I am in the new
doom and the system shock two ghosts
narrative mechanic upgrade tokens and
config webs expected my only minor crit
about the fantastic so far doom is the
same my half of my old franchise stop
focusing on execution so much expanding
on that last point Bleszinski said
execution animations can slow things
down maybe too much players just want to
win and kill in a shooter they don't
care about fancy animations that slow
you down in my opinion students glory
kills as they're called are contextual
attacks that show the player violently
dismembering enemies in gamespot's
review in progress our reviewer Peter
Brown said these can definitely slow
down the action but they have an upside
as well while it's fair to say glory
kills bring combat to a temporary halt
they're also a godsend as they cause
enemies to drop health packs and
occasionally some ammo have you been
playing doom are you pro or anti
execution let me know in the comments or
come find me on Twitter I'm at how not
to draw thanks for watching and make
sure to check back on gamespot com as
our review in progress of doom reaches
its conclusion